[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the nfl season is over but the road to
the nfl draft has just begun welcome to
draft crash course live in the bleacher
report app we will be here every
thursday at 1 pm eastern time until the
main event i'm connor rogers the lead
nfl draft analyst here at bleacher
report joined by longtime friend long
time college football analyst michael
felder how we feeling
man i feel good i'm over here at stadium
but it's nice to kind of take just to
get back together with my buddy connor
rogers doing his thing i loved it listen
you've got the hair up here i got the
hair down here baby
looking good man i can't wait to get
into this today we got a fun show
planned we got to start with it right
the blue chip prospects of this 2022 nfl
draft class the top guys the guys that
can be foundation players for your
favorite team we're not going to stop
there we're going to take your questions
as we always do live in the app so fill
it up and then of course we're going to
do a little divisional preview and we're
going to start this week this series
with the nfc north and it's not just
going to be the packers the lions are
going to dictate a lot of the strap we
got the vikings we got the bears they
got to help out justin fields so we will
get to that down the road but felder
let's waste no time i think the talking
point the starting conversation of this
draft is the past rushers and the guy
coming off a massive massive season he
was on the heisman ceremony and aiden
hutchinson 2020 loses a lot of this
season due to injury comes back to
michigan when he could have declared and
just dominates off the edge stand up
hand in the dirt you name it and now
he's in the conversation not just as a
top five overall pick but potentially
number one to jacksonville or maybe even
a lock to those lions at two felder you
evaluated his growth throughout his time
in this defense and he exploded this
year what do you see with hutchinson
that makes him a blue chip prospect
yeah i think growth is the key word here
conor because this is a guy who was good
and now he went from good to great we
can go from good to great now you've got
an opportunity to make big things happen
and you see him playing in these games
and you see that to me it's the hands
right those hands are remarkable the
hands his ability to swipe down
is huge because tackles want to push to
you you swipe their hands down now you
got an opportunity to go either way he
has underrated speed i think people
don't realize that this is a guy that
can come off the ball and go make a play
so i think that's important the other
part of it for me in terms of
elemental-wise what he does what he
brings to the table the other part of
that is his ability to
kind of be versatile right like he can
play hand down but he's usually a
stand-up guy but he can go inside or
outside and he can beat you both ways
and i think the ability to do all those
things having um
the proverbial toolbox if you will
having a lot of tools in your toolbox
makes you a more valuable player and
that's the reason why aiden hutchinson
especially as a guy who honestly
i'm not going to say he's going to get
david ojabo drafted in the first round
but
he did enough stuff for teams to focus
so much on him that ojaba was able to
have another come up and there's only a
handful of guys that we've seen that
with we've seen it with clowney
obviously seeing him get other defensive
linemen drafted we've seen it a couple
other times but the reality for me is
and i don't think hutchinson is a clowny
but i do think that he is a worker he's
an earner he's someone who's going to go
out and get the job done because he has
so many tools in his toolbox he is
in elite level handyman in terms of
he'll show up at your house he'll fix
your window then he'll fix your sink
then he's also gonna go out there and
like when you think about it in football
terms he's gonna stop the run he's gonna
get to the quarterback he's gonna
disrupt the screen game he's gonna do
all those things and that's what i mean
by tools in a toolbox
yeah i love it felder i think you nailed
it and you talk about the growth he's
spoken about just you know they adopted
a lot of the ravens principles of what
their front does and it unleashed him it
absolutely unleashed him i think he's so
good at making tackles set really wide
with his speed and explosive nature that
it's allowed him to develop a counter
inside move so hutchinson one of the
high floor players of this draft and
that's why he's gonna be taken really
really early but that's a good time to
transition to his counterpart the guy
that we have heard for years is gonna be
a future number one overall pick in k
von thibodeau now he's projected all
over the place and my goodness you see
the speed to power right there with kt
he is explosive off the edge you see the
long arm move there the khalil max
special is what we call it and then the
ghost move the ability to use speed off
the edge and dip and climb into the
pocket so for thibodeau he's been the
real deal since he stepped on campus at
oregon he's been a productive player and
he's grown as a player from 2019 2020
now 2021 a year where it looked like he
was even playing hurt at times so
thibodeaux projected as the number one
overall guy now hutchinson maybe has
surpassed him at least in a lot of mock
traps but seems like a no-brainer top
five pick and a future stud as a pass
rush past rusher at the nfl level
oh wait connor you mean to tell me that
a guy that's playing with a bionic like
a brace on his elbow might be a little
bit hurt
like
it's one of those things watching him
he he did everything he could to try to
make organ bet be good right like he did
everything he could and then
i think that that speaks to what he is
as a player in terms of being a teammate
but i also
looking at him i mean this is a guy and
you mentioned 19 20 21 i mean i'm gonna
go 17-18 when he was in high school and
he made oregon's class
and he's going to make somebody's draft
class he made their recruiting class at
oregon and he's going to make somebody's
draft class he's going to be the focal
point in the centerpiece and i do think
that there's something to
the off the field side of understanding
that i am the focal point and i better
produce because he did produce and when
you're in that position
and the pressure is on you and everybody
is looking at you you have to be able to
stand up to that spotlight and so he has
that ability in space i love that about
him you mentioned you rattled all i
didn't even have to run off all the
things you rattled them all off you ride
it off the long arm the the speed to
power ratio the ability to play that
ghost that ghost like now you see me now
you don't like he did all those things
and
i mean to be
i think about and and obviously this
year was kind of up and down up and down
up and down i think about a year before
this year he was a one-man wrecking crew
against utah in the pac-12 championship
game he did everything and he got to the
quarterback he stopped the run he ran
guys down from the backside he did
everything and so
he
i don't like to use the phrase higher
ceiling when we talk about hutchinson
versus thibodeaux or thibodeaux excuse
me but
how do you pass on them i i get that how
do you pass on how do you pass on kayvon
you don't and felder that's where i want
to take this conversation before we move
to a different position group
i'm not moving him from the number one
spot i think he is the best overall
player in this draft class i think he is
as good of an athlete as hutchinson is i
think thibodeau's explosiveness is in a
different tier from a really good pass
rush class there's no doubt about that
but when you put all three years
together of tape and you know from
evaluating these guys as recruits it's
not just the three years it's living up
to that status and carrying it over to
oregon and then we think he's going to
carry it over to the nfl do you think he
is the blue chip guy of this class the
best of the best
yeah i i think he's got undeniable
traits and that matches up with his and
we'll get into this as we get into the
show over the next few over the next
several weeks but he has traits that
match his production
and or it's gonna be production that
matches his traits right this is we're
not talking about dorial green beckham
right we're talking about a guy who
actually goes out there does everything
the right way gets it done and makes it
happen and so
honestly the only reason you pass on him
is if you
you don't like him in interviews and i
think that's going to be an interesting
element because we have to add that when
we talk about i i say that i call it the
holy trinity right where it's we have
film
then we've got your your your your
measurables the combine and all those
things and then you've got this other
element which are your med checks and
your interviews that holy trinity is
where how you end up getting drafted
somewhere so we'll see because if you
have a failure in one of those parts you
can fall and we'll see what happens we
saw it with randy moss right had the
film had the measurables didn't have the
other part of it and that's why we saw
randy mossfall even though he's in my
mind the greatest receiver of all time
but the reality here is came on
thibodeau the thing for me he has the
film he has the measurables now we'll
see what happens with the next step i
wanted to ask you this this is him i
wanted to to toss to you
where does he fit in the pantheon in the
last
decade of past rushers
it's a great question i like to look at
someone you know like a brian burns i
think he's a little bit above that and i
loved brian burns i thought brian burns
was a no-brainer top 10 selection uh
would come in and be very productive
right away and he's had a good career
especially when healthy i don't think
he's you know let's not try to make him
miles garrett let's not try to make him
chase young you know let's not even
maybe make him one of the bosses who
obviously we're really special players
but i think when you look at that brian
burns tier even being a little better
than what he was that's a really special
player at the nfl level in terms of how
premium edge pass rush is and i like
that you brought up the holy trinity
when that last leg of the tripod what we
don't get to see we don't see the
medicals on tv we don't see those
interviews on tv those are what teams
like to keep to themselves for good
reason that's what's going to dictate
the ceiling of tbo if he's a number one
overall pick if he's the number five
overall pick but i think at the end of
the day he won't make it out of that so
let's move to the offensive line because
this is a loaded group and this is a
this has at tackle the big three for me
and then obviously the one center that
is a special special player so let's
start with the big three out of the
tackles and we'll keep this with ikem
ekwanu from nc state who just had a
monster year at left tackle for them he
came into the season and a lot of scouts
were looking at him and saying okay well
he has some pass pro issues he might
have to kick in at guard he silenced all
of those he is a dominant run blocker he
is the best run blocker in this entire
draft he's the best run blocker i've
seen in a couple years i think the only
thing even close to him in terms of a
pure drive blocker is makai bechten
ekwan who has special power special
hands uh really heavyweight fighter kind
of hands when he and this is against
mississippi state okay he's not lining
up there against small school programs
and doing this and making these guys
look little so equano to me the top
tackle in this draft a bona fide top
five pick felder you've seen this guy
grow over the years and this year i
think even for him surprised a lot of
people he wasn't a five-star recruit it
wasn't a household name but when you
look at equanu what do you see in his
game
but he was a dwayne ledford guy
and ledford offensive offensive line
coach now for the falcons before he was
the offensive line coach and offensive
coordinator for louisville before that
he was in nc state he's a gear that's
who that's who coach garrett bradberg so
i look at this and i say oh
he wasn't a five-star recruit but you
know what he was he showed traits he
showed a nasty name and then he stepped
it up and i'm glad you mentioned the run
blocking
honestly i'm very curious to see if he
sticks at left tackle i think that right
tackle he may end is where he may end up
but he is someone that there is a
meanness and a nastiness to his game
that i enjoy and he is a fighter i'm
glad you mentioned the boxing thing
because ultimately what he does is
if he can put the paws on you he's gonna
try his
hardest to get you on the ground
and we saw him with a little throwback
they maybe call that a hold i doubt it
but like the reality of it is is once he
gets the hands on you he's going to get
you on the ground he's going to
out-muscle you and wrestle you down and
i think that's really interesting to
watch with with with him the the part
that's going to be interesting though is
what his past protection looks like
against
truly elite speed guys and that's the
part where
he is and when we talk safeties and we
talk more secondary we'll talk about
this but like i think he's way better
going forward than he is going backwards
and that's the part that gives me a
little pause
even though he is incredibly athletic
because when you see someone that's his
size get out in front
and go look for work i love a guy that's
looking for work and that's what he's
doing i'll bury you then i'll bury you
so for me when i look at him i i think
listen i love that he's coming out of nc
state north carolina as a state stand up
love it but
i i think that the question becomes how
much are you going to want him to pass
that and what do those pass sets look
like and that's where you're going to
see the value for him because if you are
going to work in more
of that rpo situation right more even
play action game if you work more of
that in i think he's going to be more
successful than some of these other guys
like even like charles cross who i know
we're going to get to
yeah i think so i think that's a great
point and that might play to his favor
when you look at how this draft could
play out if the jaguars pass on him and
we'll get to that in a second but he
goes the jets at four or the giants at
five they have left tackles so if they
like the player enough and then they
move him to the right side
that might benefit him in the long term
so i'm glad you brought up that there
might be a position move but something
that he can handle so let's talk about
someone that there probably will not be
a position move in evan neal as much as
he's played left tackle this year he's
played right tackle the year before and
he played guard before that felder i'll
kick this one to you first evan neal
everyone knows this guy the size the
power the program
talk to me about evan neal
dude evan neal from bama he's been
one of the best offensive linemen since
he was in like 10th grade i mean
he is
it's it's insane how humongous he is
like connor i'm not crazy right it's
crazy how big he is
oh my god he's him he's and he carries
the weight well felder that's what's
insane
yeah he's not sloppy he's a big guy that
moves around and you see him there and i
think the big thing for me there's two
things one
when i watch evan neal
it's a question of it's not and i don't
i hate when people talk about effort
it's not a question of effort
it's an issue of knowing you can win
versus wanting to destroy does that make
sense like there he knows that he can
win every single rep
he understands that
it's i want to see him do more seek and
destroy and i think a lot of that
changed up and down depending on where
alabama was in games and who they were
playing against georgia he's seeking
destroy against tennessee he it's
what am i my guys over at split zones do
it they call it playing with your food
right they kind of you push it around
the plate before you finally take it all
down and i think that's one of the big
things here is just
i want to see him every single play go
out there and be a heat-seeking missile
set to destroy but there's no question
of talent there's no question of ability
there's no question of
strength or size or any of those things
he is remarkable
i just wanted every play and it's not
about effort because he wins
almost every single rep he gives you
that he gives you effort to win every
single rep
i want to see
that
destruction that we just watched with
iguanu right like i want to see that
level of destruction when a guy's 350
pounds
and can move
let's bring
it i'm with you felder i think the two
things i wrote down with neil and he's a
blue chipper so this isn't this is
nitpicking
right you want to see carnage all the
time from his size because you know he
could do it and two a little bit of
balance at that size there's times where
he wins the rep and he's on the ground
and you'd rather not see him on the
ground as much but
he can get there he can clean that up
the kind of athlete he is at that size
he's going to be okay and that's why a
little sneak peek i think jacksonville
at number one would prefer someone like
him at left tackle as much as i like
equano a little more than a kwanu at
left tackle because of that pass
pass protection ceiling in a sense which
is already well tapped into but even has
room to grow and we'll take it right
there a guy with
all world pass rush ceiling and he's
really already displayed it two-year
starter charles cross here a two-year
starter at left tackle he can almost
load you to sleep at times that's how
good his feet are that's how good he is
amir this is an athlete right we looked
at akwanu the brawler we looked at neil
kind of the complete package in terms of
the size the he's the prototype you want
as your franchise cornerstone a left
tackle cross to me is a pure athlete
felder what have you seen in his game
over these last two years as a starter
i i really think that he's a guy who's
been helped tremendously and i don't
think there's a lot of guys but i think
he's the guy that's been helped
tremendously by mike leach being there
right
when you're past setting you know 60
times in a game you're gonna get good at
it or you're not going to be on the
field very long and look at his body
he's lean but he can still push right
you see him sit down on those haunches
and move a little bit but his pass set
is so he's so comfortable in it he is as
you mentioned an athlete like this is a
guy
like i'd love to watch him dunk a
basketball i'd love to watch him get out
there and hoop up hoop it up a little
bit but he's he's a he's leaner than
these other guys and even though
like nobody's gonna be as big as evan
neil but the weight that he carries he
carries it a lot more like one of one of
those basketball guys and i do think
having to pass that as frequently as he
had to
because of the style of offense they
played that's going to help in today's
nfl does that mean is he going to be a
top five guy maybe not but that might
help him too because that means he might
go through a team that has an
established quarterback
a team that is going to throw the ball a
ton because and
because you're going to establish
quarterback because you're drafting
early enough in the top 10 top 12 to get
them but you are also losing games so he
is gonna have to pass that a lot because
you're gonna have to come from behind
and those kind of things all work in
concert to push him up to make him mean
more i love his body style i don't know
that you can build an entire offensive
line in his body style but i do think
that having him as the guy
that has to track down chase young right
if you're in that what is that the nfc
east right having to track down chase
young or you're you're playing against
uh tj watt or whatever like if you have
to do those things this guy's he's good
for that because he can move and i think
that's
the greatest
compliment to him is his ability
to move and if you're an aggressive run
game he's going to be able to to check a
guy and then get to the next level so
that your running back can find a little
crease and make a cut
yeah to close the chapter on cross i
think you can trust him on an island is
what you're saying felder and that is
that's a really high praise uh saying
for any kind of tackle to trust them on
an island against top tier pass rushers
all right moving on the last guy from
the offensive line here with the blue
chip prospects and it is not easy for a
center to enter this conversation but it
has been done it has happened tyler
linderbaum from iowa and we talked about
how much of an athlete crosses with
linderbaum you're talking about a state
champion wrestler okay there's that kind
of hands and power and yes he's not the
biggest center he's going to play around
290 pounds but he is explosive in the
short area you can ask him to climb to
linebackers and he doesn't like just
climbing to the linebackers getting his
hands on them he likes climbing and
finishing his blocks and scouts coaches
teams are going to love that with a
league that has moved so much more
towards a wide zone rushing attack or
even inside zone linderbaum
is tailor-made for those things and he
has an adequate anchor at his size to
hold up and pass for on the inside
against guys much bigger than him it's
as simple as that so felder i think this
is one of the most dominant football
players we've seen in college football
the last two years at his position uh
what's your take on linderbaum
i think he's really good i just i'm i
really struggle
from a center standpoint because i'm i'm
i would love garrett bradbury then we
see where he goes in the draft i
love creed humphrey then we see where he
goes in the draft and i just
i do we think how much better is
linderbaum than those two guys right
sure
yeah so frank no
frank yeah frank yeah i just want i
wonder where it is but i think he's so
good he's super smart and one thing i
will do on the show all the time is when
i think of guys super smart i'm gonna
say it because i'm tired of people
thinking that football players are dumb
and this guy is super smart he knows
what's happening there's nothing like
watching him go deeper into the two
going deeper into the three point
and look around
this guy he's over here he's over here
or him over here this in then get back
down
he's teaching the quarterback about
football basically right like he had to
teach spencer petras
about football so that they had an
opportunity to win football games so i i
like him i think he's fantastic there's
no disagreement with me i just find it
interesting
like
how do we it's such a sliding scale year
to year when it comes to that center
position
it really is it's a position that even
if linda obama is the best that we've
seen in years or even a half a decade or
close to a decade that does not make him
a lock for the top ten and i do not
think linda bomb will go in the top ten
of this draft but he is a fantastic
player and you said smart player we're
gonna continue with that trend and roll
with kyle hamilton here you wanna talk
about smart and reliable on the back end
a leader for notre dame i just look at
kyle hamilton and think if you're a
defensive coordinator
what can't you ask this guy to do if you
want him to play down in the box he can
come down and tackle if you want him to
play too high single high in rome with
range if you want him to blitz or even
play a kind of sub package linebacker
role covering the slot against these
mismatched tight ends kyle hamilton is
the real deal he's one of the best
players in this draft it's a little
similar though to the center
conversation i think felder where
i think he'll go before linderbaum but
how high will a safety go
how high can hamilton go and why is he
this great
i mean he's a top 3-4 player in this
draft
and
simple
it's frustrating
that
safeties can't get picked that high when
especially in today's nfl
they're
some of your most important players pick
them higher like we're not talking about
running back where you feel like you can
just get a guy off the scrap heap and
steal a year we're talking about guys
who have to be able to
protect over the top come down against
the run cover a slot cover a tight end
tight ends we're going to talk tight
ends later but tight ends
aren't like we're seeing all this happen
so for me i just i i love him
a couple of the plays that he made i
think it was in the syracuse game
watching him go from the far hash to the
near sideline and make a play on the
football i'm just like you're not
supposed to be able to do that like it's
not
but it's a combination it's
intelligence mixed with athleticism
because he knows what the play is
has to show what he shows then goes
and goes and takes the ball away or goes
and bats the ball away goes and makes a
tackle he's also a really good tackler
which i don't think enough people put
value on
everybody looks at past past breakups
they look at interceptions
big hits but not enough people look at
some combination of denial football and
also
uh tackling tackling is important being
able to tackle a guy for minimal gain is
is hyper critical
i would argue tackling is as important
as ever when you look at the dominant
offenses in the nfl really stemming from
that shanahan and mcveigh tree their
goal is to get the ball in their best
players hands scheme the touches and let
them manufacture the yards when you see
debo samuel that's the first thing you
think of so
you have to place a premium on tackling
and kyle hamilton is going to bring that
on the back end or he can come up front
and do it as well let's take this in a
different direction a player that you
and i i think it's best to say struggle
with as a blue chip player but he's in
this show because you have to have a
conversation about him and that is derek
stingley obviously came on the scene in
2019 and was dominant for a championship
team the ball skills the man coverage
ability the length of speed
really the complete package at corner
where this guy everybody was saying well
if he was in this draft after his
freshman season he'd be a lock to be a
top five pick 2020 and especially 2021
which was ruined due to injury have been
a different story so felder what do we
do with derek stingley at this point
because this is a guy with all world
upside he couldn't be in that
conversation that jc horn and certain
were in last year but the reality is
from the recent sample that has not been
good enough in recent years there are a
lot of question marks that we have to
answer about him but we just don't have
those answers right now
yeah i i think the big key here is
looking at him and recognizing
he hasn't he's he hasn't played a ton of
football high production hasn't played a
ton of football obviously missed some
games in 2020 missed even more games in
2021 i think the key is watching him and
we the good thing is i'm glad we got
some of his tackles on there because
most of what he's doing is playing man
coverage so we we fit some tackles into
that b-roll but he's a guy that's super
productive he's a guy that um
he like he listen he's good he's really
good like we're discussing him as a blue
chip because the question is what how
what do we know about him right the
question mark is the question mark we
don't know enough about what he's going
to bring to the table when he gets to
the next level because we haven't seen
him play football in
by the time
seven months eight months like we
haven't seen much so i think it's going
to be interesting to see where he fits
coming out of his freshman year he was
clear cut no doubt number one overall
corner super badass ready to rock and
roll guy
and then
you start to see teams try to figure out
ways to push him in different directions
to show him eye candy so he can't play
man but also try to
pull off to pick things off or show they
do they were teams that were trying to
do a little they were playing with his
eyes and i think not getting to see him
this year nearly enough is
it's calls for pause and i think that
the question becomes
what does he show you how does he move
when you watch him in your workouts is
he healthy what does it look like all
those things are going to be really
important and so
i i like him a lot i think he's
fantastic i think in the in the kind of
the pantheon of lsu corners
i just don't think he's played enough to
go into the
peterson mo claiborne all that with that
world does that make any i think like
even like greedy like i don't think he's
played enough football to fit into that
world even though he's clearly
demonstrated very similar traits
yeah it makes a ton of sense and you're
also looking at what kind of what teams
are going to prioritize corner as a top
15 pick that are also running such man
heavy schemes obviously the giants hire
wink martindale from baltimore they're a
team that's going to do that but they've
paid bradbury and dory jackson so you
have you know somebody like the ravens
at 14 which is really intriguing but
does he make it there so let's keep that
conversation going talking about
physical man-to-man corners and sauce
gardner you and i didn't have a lot of
questions disagreements or anything with
this guy he tackles he'll throw hands on
you at the line of scrimmage felder your
former college db why have you fallen in
love with sauce
there's two things i love he's a denial
corner
and he's also kind of a swiss army knife
you see him here look this is a guy
getting a sack right strip sack uh to a
fumble like i love that right a guy that
yes he's a man corner but he is also
willing to be a part of your blitz
package he is not someone that's like oh
i just play man
he wants to do all those things and i
think his denial game
we will not see any denial clips during
this because denial clips are
they're horrible to show when the ball
doesn't go to him but
he plays denial he doesn't have the
production of a lot of other defensive
backs but what he reminds me a little
bit of is remember that run that nominee
assam wah had
where they just
didn't never threw his wallet all over
there other folks might remember it as
like dion like
what is it water covers two-thirds of
the earth and dion covers the other
third like
a revis yeah but it's this idea of you
just don't don't don't even look over
there
don't look over there
don't worry about it don't force it he's
gonna take it away from you it's gone
and so i think that the big thing for me
with sauce is just
i mean he's lean and mean right this i
didn't realize he was six foot three
because i was
like watching him i was like is this guy
five ten
and then you see six three and i was
like six three
but he's
long and lean and he's
he again again we he plays bigger than
he is but he's also got this
this this like slinky smoothness to his
game you know like it's just
nothing looks hard even there him
running around the corner to get to the
court running around the the edge of the
of the offensive line to get to the
quarterback you see him in coverage and
everything just he's a smooth mover no
herky jerky about him i love watching
him play so yeah he's to me he i think
he's the top corner in this draft and he
he can play his own but i'll tell you
right now connor every time cincinnati
flipped the play cover two or cover
three i was yelling at my television why
are you doing this
you don't need to
so i i think to close the book on sauce
he was so good this year eliminating his
side of the field
that everybody realized kobe bryant his
teammate across the him was also good
because the ball finally started to go
his way and everyone's like oh they have
two nfl corners kobe bryant's going to
go in the third round i'm with you
felder sauce is the top corner in this
class all right to close out the blue
chip prospects that we agree on here
look at the guys they gotta cover and it
starts with the wide receivers one of my
favorite players in this entire draft is
trailing berks from arkansas i think
when you look at what berks does it is
it translates so well to today's nfl
game and the little things beyond the
big things it's yes winning vertically
down the field and making the
spectacular catch he's six foot two and
a half 225 230 pounds with build up
speed like this i think he's going to
run a 4-4 which is absurd at that size
but he does the little things felder
he's so nasty as a run blocker he can
you can move him all around he's played
outside he's played a lot in the slot
the contested catch threat
massive hands his hands are going to
come in the 93rd percentile and it shows
on film you see them catch everything so
felder i know you have you have been a
big trail in berks fan as well
man this is this to me is one of the
most exciting players in the entire
draft he's awesome he's a he's a
football player and then a receiver
and what i mean by that is i love guys
that are football players first
and then they are their position he'll
do anything it takes for that team to
win
and i'll be quick quicker i know we got
a lot of show left to get to but
man
watching him and you mentioned the
build-up speed i don't know if he runs a
4-4 i think he probably he might run
closer to a high four five
but
when he needs it he can pull a 4-4 out
of his back pocket and i think that's
the ace that makes him great is watching
him against alabama watching him against
a m watching him against ole miss when
they needed him
he showed up and he was able to run away
from guys who are going to run faster
than him and he was able to run away
from them
yeah that alabama tape is real if you
have any questions about trailing burps
just turn on that and they'll be
answered real quick another wide
receiver garrett wilson to me a calvin
ridley clone in this draft and that's
because he is so good at three phases of
wide receiver before
during and after the catch he knows how
to get open with his routes he knows how
to his concentration at the catch point
and the ability to make someone miss so
garrett wilson fell there give me the
lowdown
yeah he's he's just good i mean the guy
look he knows he understands where he
fits on the field saves look at this
this is what i love buy yourself space
right a lot of receivers we see them
fade to the sideline he stays at the
numbers gives himself space now you see
after the catch look at that i'm not
afraid to do this and then concentration
okay i can make this catch in traffic
and make sure i secure the ball he does
all those things and then here's the
added value whether it's a jet or it's
an orbit that motion his ability listen
you give the guy if you let him go full
speed before he ever touches the
football behind the line of scrimmage
not many guys are gonna be able to track
him especially in man so he does all
those things the right way he's so
special and again this is we talked
about it with kayvon thibodeaux garrett
wilson's another one of those guys he's
been a star his whole life and so he's
lived up to the building he's been able
to get the job done uh absolutely
belongs on the list
an elite b-roll from our bleacher report
team of editors they're matching
everything felder and i had to say about
garrett wilson before we even showed it
to you to close out the wide receivers
here he's hurt but do not forget about
him because if he could have ran at the
combine he would have lit up the track
jameson williams one of the breakout
stars of this college football season
transferring from the room garrett
wilson was in at ohio state and
dominating at alabama this is the big
play vertical threat of this wide
receiver class you're talking legitimate
4-3 wheels and he knows how to work open
down the field right here with the
stutter the stop i mean that speed
against georgia felder this has to be a
cornerback's nightmare
yeah he's he's devastating as a player
and i think the other part here we see
those strong hands i love that but the
big key for me i think he's got an
expanded route tree and i think that's
what makes him higher value for me
than a couple of the other wide
receivers that expansive route tree at
alabama they asked him to do everything
they didn't ask him just to run phase
and ask him just to run stutters and ask
him just to run slants didn't ask him
just to run screens we saw a little
piece of that hook we saw some of the
dig we've seen the dig that he scores a
touchdown in the sec championship game
guess what or the dig or you call it
over route i don't care which one you
call it just
make it a house call because that's a
touchdown for him and the reality of it
is is
he's got an expanded expansive route
treaty he's a really good route runner
you mentioned calvin ridley we were
talking about uh garrett wilson i think
what calvin ridley brought to the table
that i really liked was this dedication
and this
focus on route running and i think that
got better at alabama even though it was
good coming out of high school
i think that jamison williams also
brings that that
focus on the craft of wide receiver and
i think that's going to go a long way
for him
because
yes he's fast but it's also not just him
being fast it's also the fact that he's
gonna stim you out to get to get inside
he's gonna do a lot of little things and
you can call any route in the book he's
gonna make it happen
yeah i'm with you i think he understands
spacing as well as any receiver in this
entire draft all right let's look at
some of the comments and the questions
before we get into the final blue chip
prospects we have here the first one
from jojo who asked us do you think
hutchinson is a lock to go number one or
are you looking elsewhere felder i i
don't i don't think this is a luck i
think we've talked about how
jacksonville is going to look at tackle
and evan neal is kind of that prototype
as former number one picks we've seen in
the past what do you think about
hutchinson as a potential number one
overall pick
i think he's going to be in the top five
i don't think he's number one i still
think that they're gonna be teams
there's gonna be there's gonna be a
defensive coordinator or defensive blind
coach that is pounding the table for
thibodeau because of what he's able to
do and so no i don't think he's a lock
to go number one i think the question
becomes
what do they want they know they have a
quarterback they love is it about
protecting that quarterback from a
legitimate like from a literal
standpoint with an offensive lineman or
is it about
protecting him as we mentioned before
by giving him a short porch by giving
him a defense that can stand up to the
other team
all right one more another question here
from b douglas six who says how much
will the combine affect these blue chip
prospects i'll start with a player we
just talked about naden hutchinson i
think that arm length is going to come
in really short i do not think it has
the impact that traditionally we'll see
but it goes back to felder's point is
there going to be a coach or a scout in
the room that says look at kt i don't
have those worries about measurements
this guy was billed as the number one
pick we like hutchinson but i'd rather
shoot for the stars with kt so i think
if there's any questions about
hutchinson you will see arm length come
up belter we've talked about some of
these wide receivers running well or not
running well are there any of these blue
chip prospects that you think there's a
lingering question with the combine or
could be a good thing
well we've already hit on jamison
williams in the injury so that that's
already done i think that burks
what he runs is going to be interesting
because i think
i expect him to run into high four fives
but if he's able to get to where you
think he's gonna be in that 4-4 zone
then i think he becomes a more that's
value-added to him as a prospect and i
think that makes him even more of a true
blue chip prospect
well felder easy transition right there
this one from johnny gibson could you
see treylen burks being the first wide
receiver off the board
yes i can now this is a flavor draft
right here you have traylin burks once
again six two two twenty five two thirty
ish or is he gonna shed some pounds and
try to get to that four four that felder
and i have talked about if somebody's
looking for size speed are they gonna go
with treylen burks is somebody looking
for
polish and route running are they going
to go with garrett wilson will somebody
be patient and take jamison williams
because they love the big playability we
didn't even talk about drake london
today so felder these wide receivers i
think it's completely completely up in
the air who goes first
yeah i i think burke's can go first a
bench if you want if you want a big dude
that's gonna make plays he's your guy uh
we didn't talk olave we didn't talk
london we there's a bunch of guys we
haven't talked about and so it's gonna
be interesting to see how this all
shakes out but yeah i he can be the
first receiver off the board although if
he's the first receiver off the board
what is that the question becomes what
does that mean for the draft because i
don't think he's going to be in the top
10 but if he's the first receiver off
the board after 10 11 12 13 in there
then what are what else are we seeing
get picked in that space
yeah that's a great question i think the
wide receiver conversation at the
earliest we'll start with the falcons at
eight maybe the jets 10 but like felder
said it's going to get really crazy
beyond that in round one all right let's
round out these blue chip prospects
because you and i each brought some to
the table
that we didn't unify on this is where it
gets fun felder you got three guys from
the same program let's hear about them
listen i am not a georgia homer i am not
a georgia fan but i wanted to put all
these guys on the list so we can get
this out of the way as we get going with
the show but the big thing for me i i i
listen there's a lot of georgia guys are
going to get picked in the first two
days of this draft but i start with
jamari sawyer i think jamari sawyer is
the reason they won the national
championship game i think he's a
i thought he was a phenomenal all season
left tackle but when they moved him into
that right guard spot and let him move
bodies i thought that was amazing
he just was so good at what he was able
to do so for me i look at him and he can
move around a little bit this guy when i
the first time i ever saw him was
in atlanta i think in 2016 or 2017 or
something he looked like uh he looked
like a ninja turtle like he you know
like how the turtles heads kind of go
into their shells that was his whole
body was the shell and he was just kind
of in there and just like a little tank
head on there so for me i gotta go
jamari sawyer first
i love hearing that name he is one of
two players invited to the combine
that's played all five spots on the
offensive line that is truly remarkable
so felder before you move on there i do
want to ask you we've seen sawyer put
out really good film at left tackle
we've seen him put out really good film
at guard where do you think his
long-term home is in the nfl
oh
man i knew you're going to ask me this
i
i i think somebody's gonna try to put
him at left tackle or right tackle first
but i think his long-term home is gonna
be guard i think it guard he brings this
nastiness and at guard you get that
two-way go where you have the ability to
be a little more aggressive and i think
the best trait that he has is his
aggression
all right moving on who else you like on
this georgia roster all right
i'm picking up the pace nicole dean i
think he's the smartest player in this
draft
i i think he's the smartest player in
this draft watching some of the things
that he was able to do
over the course of the season of the
course of the last few seasons and then
watching him in in the michigan game
watching him obviously against alabama
watching him call out motions
and then be the first guy there was
remarkable so nicoby dean on that list
for me this guy is smart if let me i'll
put it this way
if people talk about nakobi dean in the
first thing they mention is his
athleticism and not his intelligence
they are not doing him any favors
because this guy is so smart he makes
plays because he's smart he gets this
interception because he knows the play
that's going to happen because guess
what that quarterback for florida is a
freshman and he only ran like 10 plays
so we know what play it is coming out of
this formation i watch film dawg let's
go and he's got great athleticism to go
with that intelligence he's so smart he
i i he's
he's a guy he's a guy nicknamed codeine
because he puts people to sleep this guy
will bring a little hit stick to your
baby
yeah the leader of that front right
there and and i love that you brought up
felder it's not just the athleticism but
he knows where to be he knows how to
utilize that and capitalize on it when
you watch linebackers in this year's
class his ability to be where the
football is going
sometimes before the quarterback is
ready to aim there it is truly
unbelievable the ability to sniff out
screens such a screen heavy league the
nfl and with everybody running a lot of
wide schemes he can go sideline to
sideline all right to close out the
georgia conversation who is your last
blue chip prospect
i this is a question mark it's george
pickens because
does he still count as that
he was obviously a five-star kid coming
out of high school we've seen him do
some remarkable things but when you
combine the injury with
the lack of production in games that he
was in
through no fault of his own mind you and
you see here
like he can make amazing plays so i
wanted to ask you conor where do you
slot him
as a guy who we know can do things like
this
but has been hurt but also
seems to have been underused
he's a tough one i'll tell you that i
think for me he's a round two player now
what he can and can't do at the combine
will absolutely help or hurt him because
we know the size we know the ball skills
some of the tenacity on film is a run
blocker i mean this guy shows up to the
game like it's a street fight and i
absolutely love that out of a wide
receiver so how much do you penalize him
for the lack of usage at georgia the
injuries are a different conversation
we've gone over that we're not going to
see the medicals we don't know how teams
are going to value that but just in he's
a projection pick felder that's what he
is do you project him to be more
valuable and more productive in your
offense and i think multiple nfl teams
will look at that size and downfield
profile and the energy that he brings to
the field doing whatever is asked of him
and they will project a better nfl
career for him
i i agree i think that's going to be the
key i want to get to your guys who are
your guys that are blue chip that you
have as blue chip guys because i listen
i've already seen the list i want to
peek behind the curtain i've already
seen it but i want to hear the couple of
guys you got
this first one even surprised me but his
process has just been unbelievable
jermaine johnson from florida state and
there's a much longer road than florida
state whether you know the whole last
chance used story with juco to georgia
then to florida state where he's rounded
out his game as a pass rusher and then
he goes to the senior bowl and he's
unblockable so jermaine johnson i don't
know what more he can do to improve his
stock he is going in the top 15 of this
trap he sets a hard edge against the run
you can put him on the field at the nfl
level right away on first down second
down then you get to third downs passing
downs and you say pin your ears back and
go i've seen him win the corner i've
seen him win by putting hands right in
the tackle's chest and pushing them into
the pocket and he's starting to figure
out how to counter inside as well go
across their face jermaine johnsonfelder
what a story this year
he's a stud i mean yeah and you
mentioned the long road to get there but
that bulrush is nice like he when he
wants to get mean and especially he's
he's kind of like a shark right like he
can when there's blood in the water he
goes and
after he whips the tackle one time
getting those hands on him and that bull
rush
and he's like i'm gonna do it again and
i'm gonna do it again and then he's
gonna think i'm doing it again and then
i'm gonna swipe hands and i'm gonna go
outside and go make a play so yeah i
love that one that's a great pick
all right the last blue chipper for me
to throw into this conversation is devin
lloyd from utah the captain in the front
of that defense and really the true
definition of three down player for your
front seven i mean he can play so fast
coming downhill as a blitzer or a run
defender but you see some ball skills
and the ability to run and cover a true
athlete in the middle of the field that
i really think he can play mike i think
he'd play on the weak side there's not
much he can't do a pretty scheme proof
player because of how much has been
asked of him at utah devin lloyd a great
season and a true playmaker he can
create turnovers and i think when you
draft linebackers in the first round you
really have to ask yourself one are they
sound against the run two can they run
and cover and three can they make game
changing plays for our defense because
if they can't we think we can find those
first two things or some combination of
them in rounds two three four and on and
on devin lloyd checks every single box
three down player i think he should be a
first round pick
i love him he's he is so fun to watch
he's so especially in that utah front
and i'm glad you mentioned playing
multiple positions uh whether it's a mic
or a will uh even if you want to flip it
to playing in a 3-4 versus 4-3 utah was
so multiple defensively and they have an
expansive blitz package but they also
have
a lot of green dogs and he got some he
got plays on the quarterback with green
dogs which are not blitzes but plays
where if the running back blocks then
you add yourself to the fit and he was
able to make plays on those too so yeah
i i listen he's a player did not think
about him as a blue chip but i
definitely think that he should be one
of those day one guys if you need
somebody that's going to be stout
through the middle of your defense or
you need to even if you just need a
tackling machine he can be that guy
all right let's look at two comments
before we move on to the nfc north here
the first one from mbr12
is jordan davis worth a first round pick
i know nose tackles can be undervalued
felder this is an interesting one to me
he's great when he's on the field but
he's not an every down player we haven't
seen that pass rush light really come on
but he is
you can't move him you can't move him on
the inside against the run
that to me traditionally is not a first
round pick what do you think
yeah i i tend to agree with you i i'll
be honest over the course of that final
like that last the sec championship game
in the kind of in the back half of the
season while people were giving him a
bunch of love saying he should be in the
heisman guy i was like are you not
watching the kobe d what's wrong with
you guys
and i was like he's not even on the
field this guy plays under 50 of the
snaps and then the way alabama exposed
him in the sec championship game that
was a knock i will say this though
because i don't want to be negative
he bounced back in the michigan game and
in the national championship game in a
way that was remarkable to show that he
wanted to be on the field he wanted to
show he could do the job and that
attitude for me i don't think he's going
to be a top 15 top 20
but if he fits for you
and he's shown you already that he's got
the attitude and the ability to do it
maybe at the end of the first round but
i'm probably with you probably a day two
guy honestly i would probably take
devonte wyatt over him a guy who's shown
me a ton
of want to know how and ability to get
all those things done so yeah it's i
don't i don't think he's undervalued i
think what the reality of it is is
he can be a problem for you when you get
into personnel packages where they can
scheme to get him in the game
they can run out 12 personnel to get him
into the football game
and then once he's in the game
no subs guess what our tight end can
play wide receiver too and now you have
to stay in the game which is what
alabama did in the sec championship game
yeah i think it's going to be a huge
question around him i'm glad you brought
up devonta wyatt who does have a good
chance of being drafted for jordan davis
a little bit more of a complete player
one more question from the comments
picking perkins asks do you think a
quarterback will be drafted in the first
round if so who i'll rattle off three
names here felder i think kenny pickett
malik willis and matt corral all do go
in the first round with the fringe guys
being desmond ritter and sam howell how
are you looking at this quarterback
class
you got somebody's got to pick them i
mean that's i mean that you can i'm sure
you can sense the enthusiasm level that
i have somebody's gonna wake up they
gotta get picked and that's the reality
of it somebody's got to pick
quarterbacks like you can't like
in in in the real world there wouldn't
be a quarterback picked in the first
round but we don't live in the real
world we live in nfl world
and there's this they're parched they're
so thirsty
for their quarterback
and so
if somebody they're those three i
wouldn't be surprised to see all five go
in the first round honestly i don't know
if g i don't know if gm's can hold their
water i don't know if they can help
themselves
i'm with felder i think there's a good
chance and i think that's going to help
a lot of other teams that do not need a
quarterback because they'll capitalize
on the good players that fall to the top
of round two and we're going to talk
about some of that right now the much
hyped and promised divisional breakdown
of the nfc north we are starting with
the detroit lions and you'll see the
team needs up on here but the detroit
lions who control a lot of this draft we
think aiden hutchinson at two is right
in the mix but on crash course we want
to bring you more than just the top ten
the first round felder and i are here to
educate you on rounds one through seven
and like i said even undrafted guys all
right the lions here to kick things off
i see wide receiver on the board there
felder who do you like for them in round
two
i'm going david bell purdue wide
receiver guy's aggressive right strong
to the football look at this great route
running gets the corner stemmed inside
creates his own space has space for the
quarterback to fit the ball before the
sideline i love all those little things
this is a guy just he's good he's tough
he's willing to take a hit i think david
bell fits into the mix he reminds me a
little bit of dj moore who came out of
maryland ended up with the carolina
panthers he's willing to be strong at
the point of contact you see him there
playing through contact forcing guys off
of him making people making himself hard
to tackle so i'm going david bell if i
go bell at that 34th pick who are you
picking connor
man i love that selection david bell
obviously a great contested catch threat
in this class they hit a home run later
on with the monroe st brown but they
need more talent there so david bell
from felder i'm gonna look at skye moore
from western michigan and this is a
little bit of hey he gets to stay in
michigan but that's not the reason for
the pick explosive plays is what i'd
like to see more out of this lions team
and that's what skye moore can bring you
see the ability to catch the ball and
get up field interesting number choice
there 24 at wide receiver with skye
moore i'd like his ability to create
yards and stretch the field vertically
he's not going to be the biggest guy out
there he might not even necessarily be
the straight line speedster not like a
jameis williams is in the first round
but he can do enough and that'll open up
their run game a little bit more and
that'll give them a chance to if not
throw down the field at least pose the
threat to throw down the field so felder
you had david bell i had sky more
different wide receivers but i think
everybody gets the overall point this
lion's offense needs weapons
yeah i i dig it man let's go uh what do
we got who do we have next we got the
the bears
so we're going with the bears
i am getting i'm going nick benito and
oklahoma he's a hybrid linebacker listen
we've talked about the bears and we know
they have to protect justin fields i
think some of the best protection that
you can offer is getting him the ball
back to have extra chances he's a young
quarterback so they need reps how do you
get your quarterback more reps by
forcing a fumble to get the ball back to
the offense how do you get your
quarterback reps getting stops on third
down so that the team has to punt to
ball the ball to them so they can get a
short porch i think that's a plus this
is a guy and i mentioned uh dj moore
with david bell i think this is a he
might have some of that yannick way uh
wow too i didn't even realize two
maryland guys
but might have some of that capability
of coming onto the screen onto the scene
being an immediate help as a pass rush
specialist and then growing into an nfl
role and i honestly even when we did
rehearsal i did not even think about the
maryland of maryland but yes
two maryland guys that i'm comparing my
guys to
yeah i think with benito you love that
he's a true stand-up speed rusher that
can just threaten off the edge there
they got khalil mac and robert quinn two
guys that are not getting any younger so
you got to start thinking now and like
you said he can come in and hold down a
designated pass rush roll on third downs
and another way to help justin fields
create those short fields get the ball
back in the offenses hands i'm gonna
look on his offensive line that i think
i'll need some help especially if james
daniels leaves in free agency and go
with tyler smith from tulsa the hulking
door frame wide offensive tackle on this
tulsa offensive line he's got the bear
strength he's got the hands that can
drive you down the field in the run game
and i just think when you look at what
the bears need to do with david
montgomery they need to develop that
power run game and tyler smith i think
it's interesting to see where his
long-term home is going to be is it
going to be left tackle is it going to
be right tackle but if you need someone
to come in and drive block and develop a
run-heavy offense that helps your
quarterback
this is the guy to do it at the range
they're in in the second round so
rolling with tyler smith hey felder
let's keep this thing moving because we
still got the vikings and the packers
left the vikings we know they need
corners there is no doubt about that
i'll
kick things off here with kyler gordon
in round two a long lean player with
recovery speed he's got ball skills
you'll see him play on the inside here
he can handle his own on the outside i
like the length i just think this is
someone that is only getting better at
the nfl level kind of that body type
like antonio camardi and even has the
concentration there on the interception
to make a play on the football so this
corner class has been highlighted by
derek stingley sauce gardner even his
teammate tyler gordon's teammate and
trent mcduffie but gordon in his own
right can come in start for the bears
and help them out felder what do you see
in gordon and what direction at db are
you going for this team
so there's a couple different things one
love that you mentioned the chromardi
comp obviously uh little known fact my
first year of college my first game i
was antonio camardi on scout team at unc
and they just said amazing play man
coverage just do whatever and i was like
okay well i'm looking at the card and it
says zone and they're like just play man
that's all he does he plays man all the
time and i think the cool thing about
gordon compared to cromartie is he can
do more than just man he is a guy that's
a well taught they didn't have a great
season at washington but what they do
have are well taught defensive backs and
i think that's something that did not go
away with the coaching change they still
have well taught defensive backs which
means he can he can fit into multiple
systems and he can be good at a lot of
different things the length is
incredible
being able to play inside verse outside
be able to play off first press all
those things that we just saw on tape i
love all of them uh we're sticking
corner i'm gonna stick corner i'm gonna
go to pick 77 a guy i know you have kind
of ranked in this range so i'm gonna go
with tariq castro fields from penn state
another guy who's good at playing that
off a guy who's willing to tackle and i
think the biggest thing is he's able to
minimize what happens in front of him
especially when you let them play in
that zone coverage
yeah i think that's a great pick for
them i think when you're looking for
value on day two you have castro fields
who had a really good career for penn
state you know got the senior bowl
invite and performed and somebody that
just limits big plays like felder said
so uh a
big bonus of having felder here amongst
many you will not find better db
breakdowns for the giraffes so we're
gonna have a lot of fun with those
everybody you're gonna know 15 corners
at a minimum by the end of this show
closing it out with the green bay
packers we do not know if aaron rodgers
will be there but we do know whether
it's him whether it's jordan love this
offense needs more whether devonte adams
is there whether he isn't because of
free agency i think he'll stay
felder we're looking at tight ends who
do you like in green bay
at 59 i'm going jalen weidermeier texas
a m tied in
i think that he has the ability as you
see here to stand up be a little flexed
out go make a play use that wide body
and this is something that those guys
learned really quickly um guess what
he's not a receiver he's wearing 85 but
he is not a receiver he is going to be
hard to tackle and i think that
toughness to tackle adds to his
versatility he can walk in line he has
them he's going to continue to get
better at blocking but he can block in
line you see the ability of him to catch
in the screen game to catch vertically
down the field he can challenge you in a
couple different ways i think he would
be a great addition whether it's roger's
earth's love i think he's a great
addition and i know that you're going
tight in two
so if you're not taking my guy who are
you taking
well i would actually love to pair them
together if they can bring back tanyan
or they then get watermeyer here's the
perfect tight end too in that receiving
mold and that's greg dolcich from ucla a
true catch-and-run threat a
stretch-to-field tight end and yeah
you'll see him in line there but really
the name of dolce's game is gonna to
make an impact as a mismatch receiving
weapon from the tight end position and
you can get him in round three i think
in this draft because of how deep this
tight end class is so when you look at
what green bay does he's got the catch
radius in the red zone he's got the
running catch ability and i think he can
really stretch the field up the seam as
a middle of the field intermediate
target that 15 yard kind of range but
you just love the explosive nature at
that size after the catch and to make
someone miss so felder you went with
watermeyer who fits green bay's offense
like a glove you're going to be asked to
block a lot in that offense you're going
to be asked to do a little bit of
everything i go with dolcich who is
maybe a one-trick pony in that mike
gaseki mold right now but can develop
but i love the tight end help that we
got green bay
yeah listen
if you're if your one trick is really
good then you're a great pony so and
that's what's happening for him so i
would love to see him paired together we
mentioned jordan davis we talked about
personnel packages but you think about
green bay running out at 12 personnel
package with one running back two tight
ends and then those two tight ends
happen to be wider meyer and dolcich and
oh no what are we going to do because we
put in our base people and we have three
linebackers that are trying to cover
these guys we got a problem so i think
it's really cool to watch i love dulsage
i think whoever picks him you better put
in some of those clear outs where you
get a takeoff to a post and then you
sneak him in behind out of that trips or
out of that wing shot so that he can
catch as you mentioned that intermediate
route right at 15 to 17 and then he got
a problem as we saw on that tape down
the field against the safety in a corner
he's not easy to tackle either he's
still a big boy i think a lot of folks
think oh well you know he's a pass
catching tight end he's going to go down
easy and it's like no no no
those guys still like lift weights with
linebackers like they're strong they are
very strong
all right let's recap what we did to
help the nfc north an early preview for
the nfc north strap we got the lions
there we expect hutchinson with the
second overall pick and then some kind
of addition of david bell and scott
moore wide receiver with 32 and 34. the
bears we're looking at offensive line
and edge tyler smith nick benito the
vikings we looked at two corners for
them and not going at 12 but more on day
two and kyler gordon three castro field
and then the packers to close this thing
out we took a look at how they can
improve that tight end room robert
tunian a free agent coming off injury
jalen wademeyer and greg dolcich two
totally different tight ends that would
actually complement each other really
well so before we get out of here going
to read a couple comments and felder i'm
going to throw a question your way when
we're done from the comment section
first one from michael greg dolcich
round three or four is a steal i agree i
think it'll be round three m kent 93
rogers to the broncos lock that that
would be an interesting conversation for
this show alonzo soto says really good
tight end depth in this class i agree we
didn't even talk about jake ferguson
daniel bellinger isaiah likely we will
have plenty of those guys on shows down
the road felder as promised this from
anthony thompson who said you think
there is a chance strike london falls to
the late first for detroit they are
picking at 32.
that was one i i was like man
hi
i literally i was gonna ask you drake
london where does he fit
especially in comparison to george
pickens
because now you get into this discussion
of do you want the guy you know versus
the guy that you don't know what he can
actually be because he wasn't actualized
in college london was a guy that was
force-fed the football
essentially
and so we know what his production looks
like i love him i think he's great and
obviously i think he's probably going to
end up being a first rounder with
pickens being a second day guy
i don't know that he's gonna get if he
if drake london gets picked in the first
round he's not gonna last all the way
until the end
i agree felder i don't think he'll be
there for them you just look at the
board the way it plays out if somebody
doesn't love drake london in the top 15
and you know he'll go through the
medical process and all that but i think
he's first round bound just outside of
the top 15 you have the chargers if they
lose mike williams in free agency you
just slide drake london into that role
for justin herbert you have the saints
that need a wide receiver new england's
still looking for that contested catch
threat at 21. the raiders need wide
receiver as well so drake london to 32
probably not happening but if you want a
package 32 and 34
you can go up and get them there's
always that ability to trade in the
draft
all right and that's a wrap on the first
episode of crash course bellar how are
we feeling man this is the easy one to
get out of the way before we have some
real fun down the road
listen man i'm ready for the real fun
i'm ready to get into the nitty-gritty
and and you know what really make the
make the folks pull at film work because
we're gonna be pulling out names baby
this is gonna be fun connor
yeah they're gonna be busy with those
b-rolls and we're gonna be busy here
every thursday at 1 p.m we will be live
in the bleach report app on bleacher
reports youtube follow be our gridiron
to keep up with us draft crash course
every single week until the nfl draft we
will catch you next week before the nfl
combine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you